foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar the
evolving landscape of lung cancer
treatment I am Shelley Mulock of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them in the ask a question box and
click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Professor Michael Thomas Professor
Michael Thomas heads the department of
thoracic oncology at the thorax Clinic
University of Heidelberg and is a member
of the board of directors of the
national Center on tumor diseases in
Heidelberg
for a complete biography of today's
speaker click the name in the presenters
window
Michael you mean I'll break in your
presentation
hello my name is Michael Thomas I'm the
head of the Department of thoracic
oncology at thesaurus clinic at
University of Heidelberg
and today I would like to go with you on
a journey on the evolving landscape of
lung cancer treatment
here are my disclosures and my focus
today will particularly on non-small
Salon cancer and at the key date of
diagnosis around 60 percent of patients
present with local Regional disease and
40 of patients have metastatic disease
and if you would step
back 20 years ago we would have had this
counseling situation in the metastatic
disease scenario
unfortunately there is no cure there
isn't even a race for a cure and this
due to the
um results here from the comparison of
different chemotherapy regimens
published in the New England Journal of
Medicine and you see uh independent
which combination you would have chosen
two years of our rate is around 10 so 9
out of 10 would not be still alive after
two years in the metastatic scenario
with this type of treatments and this
has changed substantially as you see
here this is an epidemiologic analysis
published 2020 in the New England
Journal and this is reflecting a lung
cancer incidence and incidence-based
mortality gender specific in men and in
women it's based on the U.S CR registry
and the blue curve is representing the
incidence in total and you see
fortunately the incidence is dropping
down in men substantially and in women
modestly
but the mortality rate is even dropping
down steeper at least since 2013
minus 6.3 for men and minus 5.1 for
women it's the steeper steeper drop down
than the incidence and this shows there
is something in in the population that
now is
improving the outcome in this reducing
mortality and this has been indeed the
introduction of targeted treatments uh
five to eight years prior to this key
date of 2013.
and here on the next slide you'll be the
molecular pie chart it's it's very
important to know the molecular subsets
particularly in adenocarcinoma and as
you see around 50 percent of patients
could be attributed to different
molecular phenotypes which are prone to
charge treatments and this patient
populations
will really benefit from this type of
treatment with a differential effect in
outcome which I will elucidate in the
next minutes while we walk further into
those treatment conceptions
um the first one and the most prominent
one introduced uh into this molecular
scenario has been the egfr mutation uh
so molecular alterations of the EGF
receptor
and here this cartoon reflects the
response rate on the one hand and
progression-free survival on the other
hand and in first line treatment we see
a response rate of around 75 percent for
instance for Aussie meritnip
um a tqi which has been introduced into
the treatment scenario around five four
or five years ago and you see the
progression free survival time in the
median is 18 to 19 months and the blue
spotted box is indicating median overall
survival it's 38.6 months for this
compound though this is something which
really offers a benefit to the patients
with this alterations
and um at least it's important then if
patients elapse to control with this
type of treatment are there further
underlying molecular mechanisms of
Escape that could be perhaps utilized
for next treatment steps and so it's
very important to have a re-biopsy or at
least a reassessment of a change of the
molecular pattern which is at best done
by tissue
or if it's not possible by circulating
tumor DNA and on the left hand you see
again the molecular pie chart of
molecular alterations after failure
first line Aussie motility treatment
and in the lighter gray
where it is a type part of the pie chart
indicating transformation that means
that those patients experience
transformation into small cell lung
cancer and this only can be diagnosed on
on the tissue biopsy
and here in the molecular scenario you
see most prominent and predominant are
met amplifications
which is yellow colored it's around 15
percent of the patient population in
particular for this part of the
population
treatment
opportunities are out at least in the
context of clinical trials we have seen
last asmo the results from the inside to
trial The Phase 2 trial which has
explored ozymeritinib in combination
with tabletnip which is the cmat
inhibitor and you see response rate
is needing 50 or even higher so it's
effective this combination and the
enrichment strategy and detection
strategy for those patients has been
based tissue based on fish analysis or
liquid biopsy based on NGS analysis by
the Arca technology and threshold has
been a met copy number gain of 2.3 in
the liquid or over 5 in the tissue and
by this enrichment strategy this
combination is exerting those effects
that I just showed and further
opportunities are around in those
patients with matte alterations or with
met amplification particularly after
failure of first line was
so a further opportunity for instance is
a combination of army one turn up with
larcetinip and we want an app is a
bi-specific antibody targeting cement
and the EGF receptor
and here in combination with larcetinip
which is uh which is a third line a tki
tackling the EGF receptor as well and
this combination as you see exerts
efficiency rates around 33 percent and
Aussie martinip and zavolitanib is again
a combination with a matte tki it's a
other compound than tablet unit if you
stick to the cmat domain
um here you see that these opportunities
are broadly set up and uh so it's not
only Templeton which is in the field
it's savolitanib which is tested or I
mean one turn up with lazertinip and if
we walk further forward what are other
options if patients elapse towards uh
tki treatment options antibody drug
conjugates walk into the field as well
and uh the Bose to mention here is patri
to map de rookstikan which is targeting
her three and tatopo to map The Rook
stick on which is targeting uh drop two
and you see those antibody drug
conjugates exert similar response rates
30 to 40 percent anybody uh drug
conjugates
uh by
um this conceptual slide are designed in
that way that we have a toxic payload
that is linked to the FC fragment of the
antibody and the Fab fragment then is
detecting the respective antigen after
antigen binding the internalization Via
endocytosis
is then
there and with that then
the lysosome is then degradating
intracelliary uh this antibody drug
conjugate and then a release of the
toxic toxic payload is taking place and
toxic payload might exert efficiency
intracellular on the One Hand by DNA
intercalation or on the other hand by
microtubule disruption and then drive
forward apoptotic cell this so this is a
mode of action of those antibody drug
conjugates
and which I would like to emphasize and
stress it's very important
to even know very tiny populations which
Prevail in the one to two percent range
if it comes to Target treatment because
those charged treatment options might
offer a substantial benefit to patients
and one example for instance here are
egfr Exon 20 insertions it's insurgents
so we still discuss on alterations in
the EGF receptor and here it's Exon 20
insertion it has a prevalence of around
one to two percent with different
insertion types even here
those
tumors characterized by these insertions
carry averse prognosis and are a good
Target for various new options and here
again amiwanta map this by specific
antibody that I already met mentioned is
in the field and received approval for
second line treatment
it's here in the colored box highlighted
I mean one time up tested in the
Chrysalis trial package is showing
response rate of 40 percent and the
median duration of response of 11 months
but you see this scenario is is getting
more and more crowded further tkis are
introduced and tested mobile crtnip here
to mentioned or soon was there tnip cln
081 we have
seen last Esco for the first time in a
phase phase one setting showing response
rate of 40 median duration of response
of 10 months and a particular feature is
that this compound is showing a very
good brain efficiency if brain
metastasis are a cure and if you call
compare here by this
reflection early trials mobile security
nib is exerting the best median duration
of response with around 18 18 months and
overall response rate of 28 28 so this
is just to mention that there is a
plenty of opportunities for a tiny
patient population
and the molecular landscape has been
nicely assembled here in this pie chart
by Daniel Tan
he published this oversight paper in jco
last year and the outer part of the pie
chart is reflecting the Asian population
and the inner part of the pie chart the
Western population and you see in the
Asian population it's less than one
third of patients that have a molecular
undefined type of disease for the
western part of the population it's
around 40 so there are here are
differences and which I would like to
stress again are the tiny patient
populations egfrx on 20 Insertion I did
already mention and other representative
are heard too Exon 20 insertions which
Prevail around 1 22 percent in total and
here we have an ADC an antibody drug
conugate which has been introduced into
the treatment scenario trust to zoom up
The Rook stick came tested in the
destiny trial package and you see in
advanced treatment lines here an overall
response rate of more than 50 percent
median duration of response nine months
and here in the slide different
different doses are depicted and for 6.4
milligram per kilogram body weight
um we have to see and we have to
notice that the
um rate of interstitial lung disease or
pneumonitis is quite relevant here in
this trial it has been 14 in the lower
dose it's only around six percent and so
it's important to know that and step to
the lower dose if you start this uh if
you start this ADC uh because
pneumonitis is is really important it's
really mattering to patients and you
could at least diminish the risk by
stepping down down in the dose and here
in this trial it could be shown that it
shows equivalent efficiency in terms of
response rate the lower dose so it's
always important to balance against
Society effects and and see what is the
utility and efficiency of those
compounds
I now step back to the pie chart that I
already showed and you see one further
relevant domain uh K res altered
patients in total these comprise 25
percent of adenocarcinoma patients and
around 50 percent of them have KRS g12 C
alteration here in the pie chart
reflected as 14 of the total population
and here
um you see uh here is again the taxonomy
KRS in total 25 percent KRS g12c 12 to
14 percent
and here on the right hand there is a
list of different gdpas Inhibitors that
block the k-res protein in the inactive
State and you'll see this is very
crowded it's reflecting here more than
12 of those gdpas Inhibitors so it could
be shown that their efficiency might be
exerted by blocking KRS in the gdpa's
state
and the field is getting crowded very
quickly the first efficiency readouts we
have seen on Sota Rashid and other
aggressive here in comparison in the
discussion
from last Esko and we see in the phase
two settings that response rates are
around 40 percent with median duration
of response of 8.5 and 11.1 respectively
medium progression freeze arrival around
six months median overall survival
around 12 months so no major differences
between those gdpa's Inhibitors
and sotara zip then made it Forward into
the phase three trial setting and the
results of the phase three trial in
comparison here so the reciprocal in the
second line setting have been presented
at last asthma
and you see here in in phase three
response rate is 80 is 28 phosotara zip
compared to 13 for dorsotaxial and the
one year progression free survival rate
is 24
percent compared to 10 so there is an
advantage but it's not so tremendous
tremendous it's there and so the recipe
received approval for treatment so it's
an a further accomplishment here in
those treatment lines and further
offered to patients that could help to
control the disease for a certain time
period in terms of overall survival with
a crossover rate of around one third of
patients with those attack cell crossing
over to certain recip no difference in
overall survival could be shown
so with this results it seems to be
important to think about okay how the
effect could be increased perhaps by
combination strategies uh with other tki
options that interfere potentially with
the raspathway
or with uh other options that increase
immunogenicity with i o combinations
this is depicted here in this graph and
the graph as well depicts that with with
gdpa's inhibition of KRS g12 CBC
response rate of 30 to 40 percent and in
those patients with this alterations we
even see if you look on chord
Explorations that immunotherapy might
work in a substantial proportion which
is completely different in the typical
charged treat Target populations prone
to Target treatments with the classic
egfr alterations
l858r in Exon 21 or xl90 deletion or
alkene fusions rust Gene fusions red one
red Gene fusions here we see response
rates
um
um tackling 80 percent and those uh uh
defined populations are not prone to
immunotherapy immunotherapy is not
working efficiently here though these
are differences
and which what I would like to stress
it's important to think about how to
increase the treatment in efficiency in
the careers population by the options
that are outlined here
so to summarize here if we put this into
an overnight table we have to state that
by the various options of Chartered
treatments according to the respective
molecular alterations we have the
response rates as outlined here and
progression free survival times as uh
depicted here in the table as well and
overall survival and median overall
survival as depicted here in the table
and you can take away that for the
classic egfr alterations
median survival might even might even
need 38 39 in the median by Aussie
metinip which I already have shown so
this is let's say in that way the best
population with the best benefit in
terms of tigai treatment
now I would like to jump over to Gene
fusions and here to name four potential
Fusion genes elk red and track one and
Ross one and if you look with those Gene
fusions again on the table you see for
instance for Elk you could achieve a
five years a while rate of 60 percent so
this is really tremendous step forward
for those patients and in the patients
with red fusions three-year survival
rates of 57 percent are already parted
and is further follow up of those trials
even might meet a five-year rate or 50
percent as well here so these are really
substantial steps forward in the gene
Fusion domain and it's very important to
detect those Gene fusions and here to
say that besides DNA NGS for the
mutations RNA NGS for the gene fusions
is very important and a very important
tool when it comes to Diagnostics and
even with RNA and GS you can
you can confer further informations to
the treatment of patients for instance
the fusion partner can be described by
this methodology and here I would like
to show you on this cartoon
the biological background in the Alp
Gene Fusion scenario and here are some
of our own data integrated as well which
we which we achieved and provided by
code exploration our own patient cohorts
that we diagnosed with this type of tree
this is type of disease and which we
treated either with chemo or tki options
and you see again the molecular pie
chart indicating elk is comprising three
to five percent of the total population
in Arduino carcinoma the gene Fusion is
defined by an inversion of the short arm
of chromosome 2 with a defined cut point
in the L domain various cut point cut
points in the email for domain and
according to the cut point in email for
then you have as a readout different
variants in the protein and the most
prevalent ones are the variant B1 V2 and
V3
and
um you see if V3 is given those patients
up front show a higher metastatic burden
and substantially shorter time intervals
of regression-free time progression free
survival with tki treatment so they step
very quickly forward from progression to
progression and then succumb earlier
than those ones with V1 or V2 due to
their disease
and this we detected and this we
explored by the iron torrent empty seek
technology
and and and could show that this is
given in this population in addition we
could show that the occurrence of a p53
commotation is conferring to even worse
outcome either as an upfront alteration
there the preference is 20 or if it
occurs over time and here an additional
incidence of 20 has to be stated and
this we could check by ctdna tracking
over time the occurrence of
p52z commutations
and we could uh we could even detect by
City DNA tracking early relapse of
disease by uh looking on the variant
frequency
and this indicated relapse with a lead
time of four months prior to relapse in
the imagings
and in addition uh by doing in-depth
analysis of the ctdna we even could
could check back is there a resistance
mutation in the uh in the elk
Gene given which could then offer a next
type of treatment potentially as it's an
untargeted resistance that is securing
here so a lot of information by doing
appropriate genetic analysis upfront and
even over time and with that I would
like to State here
with particularly with the genomic
landscape which is now a background of
disease and non-small cell lung cancer
definitely to say one size does not fit
for all and you really should know with
which part of your of the population you
are dealing with to employ appropriate
treatment and to move forward into the
target treatment space
a major step forward a really transition
of the treatment field
has been given by
employing tumor in micro tumor micro
environment to eradicate cancer and
really go further forward to cancer cure
and here a landmark trial has been the
keynote 024 trial which employed
uh a pd1 checkpoint inhibition here in
this case pamperism up
um against metastatic non-small cell
lung cancer and this opportunity has
been compared to chemotherapy
combination chemotherapy which has been
the standard of care in these times and
the updated trial showed in 2021 that
the five-year survival rate with
checkpoint inhibition in the pdl-1 high
expresses expressing impedial one of
more than 50 percent uh The Five-Year
survival rate here has been 30 percent
compared to 16 percent with combination
chemotherapy though this has been really
stepped forward and the proof of concept
in this treatment field
um and here again uh the molecular
landscape
might play a role at least it has been
shown in this retrospective analysis
published 2021 by recuting co-workers
just in this population that I just
mentioned with the pedialix pedial one
expression of 50 or higher exposed to
this type of treatment
with pd1 inhibition in this case
temporary Zoom map it could be shown
that those patients that in their tumor
carried a Keras mutation and in addition
an SDK 11 or cube mutation
showed worse outcome
as represented here by the red Curves in
the upper part of the Kaplan Maya plot
compared to the blue curves those are
the one with KRS mutation but without
additional SDK 11
and this is completely different if it's
KRS wild type here those additional
mutations don't matter outcome is
similar so here it could be shown that
this molecular features matter to show
how the prognosis is looking like and
how the outcome according to this i o
monotherapy is different
and this might give might might give
um energy to the hypothesis and raise
the hypothesis that those patients for
instance with Keras mutation the SDK 11
mutations need a different type of
treatment up front than i o monotherapy
or chemotherapy with IO monotherapy I
will come to that back later with my
presentation at least if you look on the
pie chart on not on the pie chart on the
overview graph
showing us the different treatment
options in first line metastatic
non-sman cell lung cancer you see it's
it's it's plenty of options and the
iteration according to the respective
treatments is driven by the pdl1
expression and the strategy and we see
independent from histology in PDL and
pdl1 high expresses over 50 percent we
have different trial options keynote 24
in power one 110 and power or one
which are reflecting different compounds
from the pd1 or pdl1 treatment options
and those are temporal zoom up Artisan
map and significant map to name the
those here and then moreover according
to histology there is keynote 189 and
keynote 407 or info 150 in power 130
these are trials that combine IO
monotherapy with chemotherapy and these
are further options that are introduced
into the treatment landscape here in
addition
and just now Empower O3 received
approval in patients with a pdl1
expression over one percent
independent from histology and this is
symmetry map in combination with any
type of chemotherapy
in combination with chemotherapy and
here again then combined IO approaches
these trials are Checkmate 9la and
Poseidon and in Checkmate 9la It's a
combination of
ntpd1 with anti-ctla4 and Poseidon is
anti-pdl1 with anti-ctl F4 so it's pd1
and pdl1 this is the difference between
those two trials and as the uh
a Poseidon trial just now received
approval I will show you that in the
next minutes but first I would like to
introduce you a little bit on the
efficiency rates long-term efficiency
rates of
chemotherapy combined with IO
monotherapy and here chemotherapy with
ntpd1 treatment and the first compound
introduced in the field here has been
again temporalism up and we see in this
combination strategies The Five-Year
survival rates are meeting a proportion
of 20 percent in the total population
it's 19.4 and 18.4 according to the
respective histologies and I already
introduced you into the results from
keynote 024 where we had a five-year
survival rate of 30 percent
in the highest addressing population and
this again is met in keynote 189 in
combination with chemotherapy again 30
percent and in the keynote 407 it's not
so much favorable it's in the midst of
the 20 range for squamous cell carcinoma
so uh but in comparison to chemotherapy
these are really steps forward again
here and uh these are a further
opportunities combination of
chemotherapy with i o monotherapy for
those patients and if we sum this up in
an oversight table we can state that by
these options five-year survival rates
are 30 percent in the high expresses and
around 20 percent in the total
population
if you look on stage 3 DCS which is
local Regional advanced
mostly not prone to surgery then those
patients receive
chemotherapy in combination with
radiotherapy to control the disease
and
um some years ago
in addition
anti-pedial one treatment has been
introduced as an adjuvant option and in
this case uh do a value map and in the
trial which started that and conducted
that we saw a five-year survival rate of
the total population of 43 percent and
in the patient population with the
petal1 expression of one percent or
higher of 50 which is here the Pacific
trial and you see the both Captain Meyer
plots indicating that and this is
putting evidence in this field as well
at patients with local Regional Advanced
disease and radio chemotherapy are
benefiting from
um adjuvant
anti-pedial one treatment and in Europe
the approval is given for patients with
repeal one expression of one percent or
higher
and with this now I step back to uh the
Checkmate 9la and Poseidon these are the
trials that I already introduced to you
with a combination of anti-pd1 or
anti-pedial one with anticidaliformis
combination chemotherapy
uh and very recently Poseidon received
approval just in the last weeks and here
uh this trial
compared
chemotherapy versus chemotherapy plus
plus
anti-pdl1 dual volume up or in addition
uh in conjunction with the overload map
anti-ctl4 in this case here tremolo map
and you see
for the quadruple combination we have
the best Hazard ratio of 0.75
with a four-year survival rate of 20 for
those patients
and if you look at the forest plot we
see a differential efficiency according
to histology
and here it's indicated that the utmost
benefiters are those with the
non-squamous histology
with a hazard ratio substantially lower
than
0.75 and
here on the next slide this is depicted
if you look on the non-squamous
population we have this favorable Hazard
ratio with a four-year survival rate of
25 percent
um so some percent even better than in
the third population where it's only 20
and uh for the chemotherapy only
population it's around 10 so this is a
very huge difference here
and um it seems to be the case that
particularly for this histology this
combination has the best benefit and
here now in this part of non-squamous uh
further results on SDK 11 or duration
and keep alteration and Keras alteration
have been made available last asthma
meeting
this Kaplan Maya plots which are
absolutely exploratory have been
presented and the information is that
even due to SDK 11 mutation or acute
mutation patients with describe to
quadruple
um type of treatment
seem to benefit this is expiratory It's
retrospective it's a signal that shows
that that perhaps those patients might
be forwarded to this type of combination
treatment at best but this is uh in in
my perception it's hypothesis which has
to be further explored and and validated
and is showing how important it is and
it will become in the future to have
this molecular information even in the
treatment scenario with immunotherapy
and here I would like to sum up that
substantial progress has been made but
advancements are imperative particularly
to customize ICI immune checkpoint
inhibition to the respective patient
populations and this is even
very important if you look you know on
the next treatment options that we have
available for those patients if they
fail to fasten 9 then it's becoming very
spares the opportunities and you see
here different options that have been
tested not after failure of direct chemo
IO but a failure after chemotherapy and
here we have in the second line scenario
no substantial response rates to expect
almost less than 10 percent and
progression free survival in the median
is almost less than three months so very
limited very spares options and this is
a reason why now after
failure of chemo IO different
opportunities are tested in terms of
anybody drag on your Gates as listed
here new immune checkpoint targets or
combination of checkpoint inhibition
with receptor tyrosine kindness
inhibition or um
checkpoint inhibition with anti-tigit
checkpoint inhibition so different
options are currently explored and it's
very important to deepen the
understanding and here again
a nice approach from recruiting
co-workers that has been presented last
escort meeting what did they do they
followed up their patient cohorts with
sequential biomaterial acquisition here
with sequential biopsy taking
uh and in this patient population was
around 60 patients which have been
exposed to different types of
immunotherapy they could show that uh
the genetic landscape uh if you explore
the genetic landscape in appropriate
depths could confer additional
information on the potential mode of
resistance so that they described in
around 10 percent of patients the
occurrence of an sdk-11 rotation
which
is contributing to a micro environment
which might then bring Checkmate
inhibition into an inefficiency and the
same to say here for loss of function
mutations and the better to micro Global
in and this could be detected in around
eight percent of patients so if you do
this type of exploration you might
achieve further information which might
help you
to move forward on next steps of
treatment to scavenger those patients
and induce again a remission if possible
uh and with that now I I would like to
move forward into the peri-operative
treatment setting and here uh it's
important uh to state that even in small
tumors uh let's say two centimeter tumor
one or two peribranchial lymph nodes
involved this is stage two bdcs uh the
overall survival is not overriding 50
substantially so it's very important to
have improvements here
attempts of improvements have been made
with chemotherapy
um 15 years ago introduced and we see
here that the
um
um Survivor rates are improving but it's
not substantial it's four to five
percent so it's
um a little very little step forward and
in the very recent past it has been
shown that it might be important to know
the genetic landscape here as well at
least it could be shown for activating
EG of our mutations that's the
additional treatment with ozymerity nip
is putting substantial benefit on the
Improvement of the disease free survival
with Hazard ratios of 0.4 of 0.3 and 0.2
in the disease-free survival and we note
that the Fourier disease-free survival
is ranging from 80 to 65 percent in the
different subgroups compared to 59 to 14
so substantial steps forward
but in addition to mention here or not
but perhaps for further information to
mention here that ctdna tracking and CT
DNA drop down might matter here in this
part of the population as well to guide
treatment here this nice exploration uh
from South Korea presented by Anne and
co-workers last asmo yet could be shown
that in patients treated with surgery
with an egfr alteration and they had a
huge population 278 patients
predominantly patients with stage one
disease it could be shown if patients
had no ctdna detectable up front to
surgery or had a ctdna dropped down
after surgery at a favorable three-year
disease-free rate of 80 percent compared
to only 50 percent of patients had a
ctdna
detection prior to surgery and no drop
down so the node drop downers seem to be
those ones that carry the worst
prognosis and perhaps those are the ones
that particularly benefit from treatment
with Tika eyes like Aussie martinib
um we will see an update on the at our
trial this Esco meeting and perhaps
further information on the ctdna
Dynamics are implemented here as well
and now for the last minutes I would
like to show you the impact of
checkpoint inhibition
utilization of micro environment in the
peri-operative treatment scenario the
first trial who now moved in a type of
checkpoint inhibition in the
perioperative setting has been in power
10 and this trial tested the impact of
artisulism map after complete tumor
resection and active in chemotherapy and
as you see in the patient population
with pdl1 expression there is an
advantage with a hazard ratio of 0.66
but the utmost Advantage is in the
patient population with a Peter 1
expression of 50 or higher here the
hazard ratio is 0.43 and in Europe
articulous map received approval for
this patient population and currently
patients are then tested in terms of
genomic alterations in terms of petal1
expression and those patients without
touchable genomic alterations
particularly activating EG of our
mutations
by the pillar 1 expression over 50
percent would benefit from adamant
artisanism up treatment
turning this a little bit around another
perspective could be to employ
immunotherapy alone or in combination
with chemotherapy prior to surgery so
induction new adamant from a conceptual
frame the advantage could be that you
have a broader T Cell response a more
diverse response of the T cells to
different antigens more intense response
with a higher clonality and potentially
more sustained response with a longer T
Cell propagation which of course is is
important if the tumor is taken out you
would like to have a long-standing
propagation and long-standing control of
micro metastasis and here perhaps an
early readout on the efficiency could be
the pathologic response in the resection
specimen and this is reflected here
uh this is just a taxonomy of the
different response rate PCR means
pathologic complete response MPR means
major pathological response with a
viable tumor proportion of less than 10
percent and you see here uh the numbers
with CTX with this which is chemotherapy
with immunotherapy only and with
chemotherapy in combination with
immunotherapy and you see the best PCR
rates and MPR rates are achieved with
the combination of chemo with IO with
around 30 and 60 percent respectively
and in how far this might mirror the
treatment efficiency
could be delineated from this expiratory
analysis from such an induction trial
which is Checkmate 816
three cycles of nuclear map in
combination with chemotherapy have been
here
employed in the exploratory treatment
arm and you see there are differences in
the event-free Survival by pdl1
expression at best again patients with
Speedo 1 expression over 50 benefit here
with a hazard ratio of 0.24
but in terms of outcome with reflection
on the pathologic complete response rate
you I would like to drive your attention
to the lower part here to the Kaplan
Maya plot first to mention that the PCR
rate is increased 10 fold if you employ
a new volume up compared to chemotherapy
only it's 24 compared to 2.2 and those
patients with a PCR
reflected here in the in the in the
green curve with neural chemo benefit
better than patients without a PCR and
and the hazard ratio for those patients
with uh nivo chemo uh is uh is
0.13 so it's a real benefit if this is
given
and
um
in how far pre-operative and
post-operative ctd in a might matter
here
uh so uh it uh in the upper part it's
reflected that around 50 percent of
patients with nivo chemo show the ctdna
drop down this is a green bar and almost
50 percent of those patients again show
the pathologic complete response so an
additional proxy for PCR might be the
ctdna drop down and ctdna drop down is
even indicating a superior or Worse
outcome as shown in the lower air graphs
this is an exploration by cancer
research UK published in the NLS of
oncology last year and they just
compared pre and post-operative CT DNA
and the first graph shows if no
pre-operative CD DNA is shown patients
have a better outcome
and the second graph is showing if
patients have post-operative still
sustainable ctdna detection they have a
far worse outcome with a difference in
the hazard ratio of around 10. and this
shows that perhaps the exploration of
ctdna
perioperatively might help us to adopt
treatment intensity and this uh
strategical considerations
published by Sans Garcia and co-workers
to adopt treatment according to the
ctdna Dynamics so checking back on that
might help to guide treatment in the
future and the peri-operative and
particularly the pre-operative treatment
setting is giving us various
opportunities it seems to be from a
conceptual background help to intensify
the immune response
by the markers that I just mentioned
biomarkers over time like ctdna or PCR
and NPR as a single shot readout
post-operative treatment potentially
could be stratified according to those
patient populations and it's a window of
opportunity because here different
approaches could be explored and could
be correlated with biomarkers either in
the pinpoint setting or over time if it
comes to ctdna
uh to explore different
opportunities for instance of checkpoint
Inhibitors and then adopt according to
the prerequisites represented by
exploration of the micro environment or
the genetic landscape of the tumor
itself
um treatment strategies at best to those
patients so in my perception the
induction treatment option in the
perioperative setting is at least the
window of opportunity to explore
treatment options and then perhaps could
be further
um moved forward into the treatment
setting of advanced disease or
metastatic disease and this is to come
in the very next future to design
treatments in that way and with that
thank you very much to be in this
webinar on the uh quickly evolving
treatment landscape of on small cell
lung cancer
thank you Michael for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for let's get
started
our first question for you today Michael
is in lung cancer research are there any
significant advantages in using genetic
analysis approach over traditional
techniques such as histology
yeah definitely this is the case
when you followed the presentation that
I provided uh you you recognized by this
epidemiologic analysis that has been
published in the New England Journal
about two years ago it could be shown
that there is a reduction in lung cancer
mortality in men and in women Which is
higher this reduction than the incidence
of lung cancer and this is has been
observed in conjunction with the
introduction of turtle treatments uh
terrazine kinase Inhibitors first one in
this domain has been the inhibition of
the EGF receptor and the dominant
activating mutations that have been
described here are
Exon 19 lesions and
l858r mutations in Exon 21 and these
alterations and further ones like for
instance Gene fusions and other
mutations are detected by genetic
analysis so this is not possible by
histology itself or additional IHC
stainings though you need this
technology and these assessments and if
you then employ the appropriate
treatments to the relevant patient
subgroups patients are really going to
benefit this has been shown in the
population-based analysis and if you
look cohort based if you know for
instance
this patient has an elk Gene fusion and
you introduce your property treatments
you could expect a five years arrival
rate of over 60 percent which has been
impossible and not been considerable
about 15 years ago so this is a real
strong step forward and diagnostic is
key here in this domain to have
appropriate patient iteration
wow thank you for that that's so helpful
um
the next question that we have uh what
are the benefits of qpcr and NGS
complementary with each other in transit
translational cancer research
yeah could be uh this depends at least
on the strategy that you are pursuing
and
um in in you know in which clinical
frame and in which type of exploration
you are introducing uh these
Technologies so NGS could provide you
with a complete overview on molecular
alterations that might be given so
um the NGS strategy uh is is really
important to have it if it comes to
upfront exploration of of of tissue and
the molecular landscape the patient
might carry and if you or the tumor
might carry and if you know a defined
alteration is there uh then it might be
important to track over time what is
happening is it is it
um
reappearing is it extinguished by the
treatment that you're uh that you're
conducting and uh this could be tracked
by circulating tumor DNA and if you have
this strategy here qpcr could be an
appropriate technology to track overtime
defined alterations in terms of getting
insights on the efficiency of treatment
inefficiency of treatment relapse and
this then would make sense if you can
link consequences to the insights that
you are gaining with this type of
um follow-up surveillance
wow that seems very useful thank you so
much for that
um the next question that we have is
what are your thoughts on using
multi-amix approach to identify new
Target targets and biomarkers especially
when dealing with more Precision
oriented treatments
um yeah uh multi-ohomics approaches
um might gain insights that are relevant
so for instance just to take a simple
example it could be shown by cohort
exploration strategies with in-depth
molecular phenotyping or those patient
chords that in the conjunction with
immunotherapy
immunotherapy by its own or in
combination with chemotherapy defined
populations
might have not such a beneficial outcome
for instance it could be shown that
patients that carry a careless mutation
and in addition an SDK 11 or key of
mutation
don't benefit an appropriate way from
immunomonotherapy even if they carry a
high pdl1 expression and this is just an
observation by retrospective chord
exploration if you now think this
forward and you would provide a
broad-scaled
multi-omix approach or even multi-level
characterization in addition to the
genetic alterations perhaps looking on
a cellular composition of the micro
environment if you would go for
decomposition strategies for instance
with nanostring analysis to get some
insights and information here this could
be something which really could help you
to better guide treatment options like
immunotherapy and here in the next
future combinations combination
strategies come around the corner for
instance targets that are tackling Leg 3
are under exploration just to give this
example and for this Soul Target
different antibodies are currently
tested so it's getting very quickly very
crowded and here
appropriate guidance would be key and
here multi-ohomics could be something
which is really going to matter in the
future and again here it's important to
link the strategies to appropriate trial
exploration efforts
um to gain relevant insights to better
customized treatment
thank you
um we have time for one more question
today our last question this morning is
how is the introduction of different
ways in treatment of lung cancer as
mentioned in the webinar relevant on the
basis of population extent
yeah it's it's very important uh as as
you uh perceived
um immunotherapy has been introduced in
the field uh starting in 2016 2015 2016
uh first in second line metastatic
disease then in first line metastatic
disease in defined patient populations
now it's spread overall in the
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer
field in local Regional Advanced disease
and it's now even moving further forward
into peri-operative treatment options in
the perioperative treatment field and so
here in the future it will be very
important to better Define patients up
groups that benefit from defined
strategies I just mentioned combination
efforts that are currently undertaken so
it's it's it's very important for the
next 10 years
to better understand which patients
upgroups might benefit from which types
of combination either in the field of
immunotherapy or in the field of
molecular alterations further example
that we can cut out of my presentation
is for instance KRS mutation g12c there
is an effective treatment or
tki and gdpa is inhibitor it's not a TTI
inhibited gdpis inhibitor out
that shows some efficiency response rate
about 20 to 30 percent progression free
survival six to seven months so it's
efficient but it's no ultimately
efficient and here then it's important
to better understand which combination
strategies might might work here in the
future so it's very important
to to better understand
which patient subgroup in which
treatment line is benefiting from which
strategy
sure that makes sense thank you for that
um thank you Michael very important
informative presentation
um so we just want to uh ask you if you
have any final comments for the audience
today
well thanks for participating and being
here in the webinar uh as you have seen
thoracic oncology here on the example of
non-small cell lung cancer is a very
exciting field never ever this would
have been expected 15 years ago it's
it's very exciting now and there's a
bright future uh so thanks for being
with us here if you might have further
questions please forward those by uh by
mail also would be happy to answer so
thank you
so yes thank you again Michael for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
by the contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab Roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's Live Events until
next time goodbye